Democrats try to cram in there
last-minute attacks on Bernie the media
finally deem it worthwhile to ask some
basic questions of the presumptive
Democratic nominee and coronavirus tanks
the stock market i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show the ben shapiro
show is sponsored by expressvpn your
data is your business protected and
expressvpn calm slash bandits expressive
VPN calm slash Ben okay so tonight is
the final real chance for the Democrats
to stop Bernie Sanders what I mean by
that is that Bernie Sanders is obviously
on the upswing in every national poll he
is now leading he is leading in
virtually all of the state polls with
very few exceptions in South Carolina he
is trailing he's trailing Joe Biden by
just a few points but Bernie Sanders has
not been exposed to any real scrutiny a
point I've been making repeatedly for
literally months on the show maybe years
on this show Bernie Sanders is a
full-fledged communist Bernie Sanders
has not yet met a socialist dictator he
did not love or could not express love
for Bernie Sanders has been a lifelong
Marxist I mean this is without a doubt
go back all the way to his earliest days
in Vermont when he was living as a loser
in basically a run-down apartment while
his while his not wife had his child and
was on welfare and he was making videos
about Eugene Debs I'm not kidding this
was actually his youth okay when I say
his youth I mean all the way until he
was 39 Bernie Sanders was a communist
who never held a real mind to five job
okay and then use elected mayor of
Burlington Vermont by 10 votes and this
starts his political career Bernie
Sanders has been this guy the whole time
and only now are the media seeing fit to
say hey maybe we should ask some
questions about this guy like why is he
running for president and why are people
taking him seriously well tonight there
is a big Democratic debate and expect
from Michael Bloomberg and presumably if
Joe Biden has any brains at all Joe
Biden and if Elizabeth Warren has any
brains at all Elizabeth Warren to attack
Bernie because here's the reality Bernie
is not only the front-runner he is the
prohibitive frontrunner at this point
Michael Bloomberg for one is planning a
full-on onslaught on Bernie Sanders he's
the only one who brought any game to
Bernie Sanders the entire race in the
last debate when he pointed out that
Bernie a lifelong communist who's been a
loser who's never earned $1 other than
writing a book in the last couple of
years and when he did earn $1 it was off
of taxpayer dollars that that loser
has a lake house so it's easy to be a
socialist with the lake house right he'd
never been asked that question directly
to his face Bernie Sanders Michael
Bloomberg asked that well Michael
Bloomberg is gonna really ramp it up
tonight according to Politico political
reports Mike Bloomberg and a handful of
staffers spent Monday at the so-called
happiest place on earth preparing for
the bruising task ahead the next day
hunkered down at the Four Seasons Hotel
in Florida's Disney World the former New
York Mayor prepared for a mission to
salvage his half billion dollar
investments in the presidential race
with a debate performance designed to
quiet the critics install frontrunner
Bernie Sanders his momentum after a
disastrous first outing his net
favorable rating dropped 20 points in
the aftermath according to morning
consult Bloomberg's debate goals in the
Charleston South Carolina debate are
twofold one persuade viewers that
Sanders is too divisive to defeat
President Trump in November and to
sidestep landmines surrounding
complaints from women at his private
media company and his race-based
policing practices as mayor Dion cannon
is a top strategist overseeing a
Bloomberg state operations he said in a
conference called the debate tomorrow
night and the campaign in general needs
to be about one candidate and that's
Bernie Sanders we've been saying for
some time that the nature of this
contest means someone with even a small
plurality of Delegates can come away
with an outsized and disproportionate
delegate lead and this of course is
exactly correct they also point out this
is also true the Bloomberg was much
better in the second half of the debate
than he was in the first half that's
sort of getting obscured because his
first 45 minutes was so awful and so
brutal but after that he really started
taking it to Sanders and Sanders had no
good answers a top aide says we've
trained our eyes on him something the
rest of the field has failed to do eight
debates prior and a year into the
campaign Bloomberg released an add-on on
Monday a digital ad slamming Sanders for
his history on gun control and drawing a
contrast to the ex mayors a lengthy
record of fighting the NRA ironically
one of the reasons that Bernie Sanders
originally was elected to Congress is
because the NRA endorsed him over his
opponent I mean that's an actual true
story the 90 second video in an
accompanying tweet from Bloomberg states
Sanders is elected to the house in 1990
with support from the NRA and
highlighted his opposition to background
checks bill in the 1990s the other
Democrats are apparently also
considering the possibility that they
may finally have to go after Bernie
Sanders which again this feels a little
bit too little too late it feels a lot
like in 2016 when the Republicans
finally decided that Donald Trump was
legitimate it was an actual nominee and
they started training their fire and
Marco Rubio started
making fun of Donald Trump and his
genital sighs and all this sort of stuff
it was like this is this is too little
too late it feels like that with the
Democrats maybe it's not too little too
late but if Bloomberg is going to air a
campaign meaning he's just going to
saturate the airwaves with anti Bernie
ads it could theoretically have a
serious impact apparently they're going
to unleash hundreds of millions of
dollars in ads directed against Sanders
the campaign according to CNBC com plans
a multi-pronged attack including the
publication of Apple research on Sanders
it will also push our digital attack ads
focused on Sanders is record the attacks
will also attempt to highlight negative
aspects of his record on race relations
both as congressman and Senator people
within the Bloomberg campaign are also
discussing whether to have surrogates
and supporters write op-eds and show up
on TV to speak out against Sanders yeah
well I mean again this should have been
the plan the whole time one of the
things that Bloomberg campaign is
leaking out is internal polling that
shows that Bernie would absolutely
destroy the party down ballot according
to Politico Chris Cadell ago and Laura
Baron Lopez reporting Bernie Sanders's
nomination could drag down vulnerable
House Democrats trying to hold on to
their competitive districts according to
a new poll conducted for Bloomberg's
campaign the poll of voters in more than
40 battleground House districts
currently held by Democrats conducted by
Global Strategy Group for the Bloomberg
campaign and obtained by Politico from
two sources found that Sanders is less
popular than Trump and loses significant
support when hit for holding socialist
positions Sanders is a self-described
Democratic Socialist of course the poll
found Sanders essentially running even
with Trump in a head-to-head matchup
across the districts trailing the
incumbent by just one point
but Trump opens up a six-point advantage
after a list of negative messages about
Sanders his ideology and alleged
ineffectiveness in the Senate is
presented to poll respondents Sanders
potential impact extends beyond the
presidential race a plurality of voters
39% say they will be less likely to vote
for a Democrat for Congress if Sanders
is the Democratic nominee which has
doubled to 21% who say there would be
more likely to vote for a Democrat for
Congress 34 percent say would not impact
their vote at all the poll found that 47
percent of voters in competitive
Democratic held districts felt the
increased role of socialist ideas in the
Democratic Party was a bad thing 19
percent believed it was a good thing 24
percent said it made no difference this
is not a giant shock the fact is that
socialism is bad branding most Americans
are still not into it most Americans are
still not into it which may be one of
the reasons why Joe Biden
still holds a very very narrow lead in
the latest poll from South Carolina NBC
News has put out that poll and chose
Biden with the support of 27% of likely
Democratic primary voters in South
Carolina Bernie Sanders has 23% the
polls margin of error is plus or minus
6% so basically they are running dead
even so that means that everybody has to
train their fire on Sanders tonight or
he's gonna run away with this race
because if he were in South Carolina
this sucker is ova it is over so that is
the big question for tonight now the
biggest problem is that Bloomberg isn't
even on the ballot in South Carolina
which means that really it's Joe Biden
on the ballot versus Bernie Sanders and
the Biden campaign is going after Bernie
a little bit to let it too little too
late again and again Joe Biden is not
your best candidate for going after
Bernie mainly because Joe Biden is not a
sentient creature at this point Joe
Biden is not even aware of which office
he is running for at this point I'll
show you in just one second first let's
talk about how you save time and money
for your business this year I'm talking
about
due to the rush lap all those packages
down to the post office is that like a
thing that you have on your agenda or
would you be more interested perhaps in
being able to do all of this from your
home or from your office and save money
while doing it well this is where stamps
calm comes in stamps calm is completely
online which saves you time no more
inconvenient trips to the post office
postage rates have gone up again but
with sam's calm you save 5 cents off
every first-class stamp and up to 40%
off shipping rates that kind of savings
really does add up especially for small
businesses simply use your computer and
print official US postage 24/7 for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just hand it's your mail
carrier or drop it in a mailbox it is
indeed that simple
stamps calm not only saves you time
it'll save you money as well with stamps
calm you get discounted postage rates
that you can't even get at the post
office I mean it will save you tons of
money and tons of time stamps calm is a
no-brainer it saves you time it saves
you money it's no wonder over 700,000
small businesses including daily wire
already use stamps calm why would you
waste time or money like you just don't
have the time money to waste right now
my listeners get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment just head on over
to stamps comm click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage type in
Shapiro that is stamps comm enter
Shapiro again stamps comm enter Shapiro
ok so Joe Biden is in fact going after
the way he's going after Bernie is
saying that Bernie was not sufficiently
loyal to Barack Obama he cut an ad that
he put out yesterday pointing out that
Bernie specifically thought about
primary about my back in 2012 when we
rallied together to defend our president
and all the progress he made they had
his back he had his back and you had his
back but back in Washington there was
one guy with another plan I think it
would be a good idea if President Obama
faced some primary opposition Bernie
Sanders was seriously thinking about
challenging our first african-american
president and our plan that is be
pointed at black voters in South
Carolina and it's an effective ad for
that I mean Barack Obama is still
incredibly popular with black voters
across the country but many voters
across the country and that is
particularly true in South Carolina
meanwhile the Biden team is also
attacking Bernie for the fact that he is
a communist so the Biden senior advisor
Alex cristóvão slammed Sanders's
comments on Fidel Castro because
remember yesterday on 60 minutes he
praised Fidel Castro he talked about
Fidel Castro's literacy programs which
is pure insanity it's pure insanity I
mean the fact is that the Cuban literacy
rate was 80% before Fidel Castro Castro
came in he promptly murdered tens of
thousands of people and imprison tens of
thousands more people and apparently
this increased literacy rates in some
way I mean it's always amusing to watch
Bernie Sanders has never had a bit we'll
get to this in in a little while but
Bernie Sanders has literally never had a
serious bad word to say about any
communist regime ever all he's had are
warm words to say what he'll do is say
oh of course I oppose no repression but
and then he'll list off a list of
wonderful glories of the Soviet Union in
Nicaraguan Venezuelan and Cuba and every
communist regime he can possibly think
of it's truly incredible so Bernie Santa
so Biden's campaign put out this
statement make no mistake
Bernie Sanders his comments on Fidel
Castro are part of a larger pattern
throughout his life to embrace
autocratic leaders and governments
across the globe he seems to have found
more inspiration in the Soviets sands
and east as Chavez does in Castro than
in America 100% true 100% true his
admiration for elements of Castro's
dictatorship or at least willingness to
look past Cuba's human rights violations
is not just dangerous it's deeply
offensive to many people in Florida New
Jersey and across the country that have
fled political persecution and sought
refuge in the United States
Bernie's comments indicate that either
fails to understand the pain and
suffering that Fidel Castro Nicolas
Maduro and Daniel Ortega have caused to
so many people including Americans now
living here or worse that his ideology
blinds him to the realities of life in
these countries we already have one
president who praises dictators in their
mob-like tendencies we don't need
another one as President Joe Biden will
stand up on the global stage against
tyrants and fight for freedom and
democracy a hundred percent true okay
everything that they are saying is what
I said about the last democratic debate
what made it so delicious is that
everything the Democrats were saying
about each other was true everything
they said about themselves is a lie
everything they said about each other
was true this is a hundred percent true
from the Biden campaign there is only
one problem Joe Biden is not alive it's
very difficult to win with an actual
dead candidate now in a general campaign
it's not actually the war strategy as I
kept pointing out I mean the fact is
that in a general election campaign if
you run a dead guy against from not
terrible manner I could do worse you can
run a live guy against Trump that'd be a
problem but in in a primary campaign you
can't really get people excited by
wheeling out a corpse on a dolly and
that's basically what they've been doing
means Joe Biden doesn't even know where
he is it's getting sad I mean this was
Joe Biden yesterday announcing that he
was running for Senate he's running for
president guys he doesn't even know
which office he is running for I have a
simple proposition here I'm here to ask
you for your help where I come from you
don't get far unless you ask my name is
Joe Biden I'm a Democratic candidate for
the United States Senate look me over if
you're like we see helped out if not
both the other by give me a look though
okay
he's not even alive he's not even alive
so that's the big problem now that
doesn't mean that that he's the only
candidate on stage tonight who's going
to be attacking Bernie that obviously is
not for Peabody judge has been trying
desperately to wrest the mantle away
from Joe Biden and suggest that he is
the serious alternative so Buddha judge
came out yesterday said we need a real
Democrat we don't need a socialist like
Bernie leading the party a revolution is
not going to do it and extreme proposals
and proper policies are not going to do
it we need a candidate that is unified
it's going to bring Americans especially
all Americans not just in the Democratic
Party but all Americans together and
frankly a man we need a real Democrat to
be the Democratic nominee and that's why
I believe a standards candidacy won't
work size does not boot
lamell McMorris who's a spokesperson for
booty judge but the but the point holds
true this is this is booty judge's
problem
this is booty judges sort of angle the
problem of course the buddha judge is
not exactly a non radical himself nor
does he have any broad-based national
appeal he has never really broken into
high double digits in the national
polling at all so the big wild card in
the debate tonight is gonna be Elizabeth
Warren Warren wants to be Sanders his VP
right that's her backup plan and it is
very obvious that this is her back-up
plan yesterday she specifically asked
about Bernie Sanders and she immediately
redirected to Michael Bloomberg and when
somebody said well wait hold on I asked
you about Sanders she started talking
about Bloomberg again she said I heard
your question she started talking about
Bloomberg so Warren Watts for Warren to
go after Bloomberg and clear the decks
for Bernie because she's basically
hedging her bets so Warren who is an
effective knife fighter I mean we saw
that on the stage the other night she is
more likely to go after Biden and
Bloomberg than she is to go after Bernie
Sanders directly so that means that
Bernie
in all likelihood continues to have this
clear glide path to the nomination this
provides a series of problems for
Democrats like a series of problems so
problem number one is that Bernie's
great why is that he's going to attract
this wave of new voters so I'm an
electoral level I mean Republicans
should take some comfort in this Bernie
keep saying over and over and over that
he's going to drive youth votes out to
magnificent rates Megan McArdle who's a
columnist for The Washington Post we had
her on the radio show yesterday she was
talking about how she saw a lot of
Hispanic voters out for Bernie she saw
young voters out for Bernie but
statistically speaking
Bernie has not actually driven voting
rates up in places like Iowa New
Hampshire or Nevada thus far the New
York Times reporting Sydney ember and
Nate Cohen it is the most politically
provocative part of senator Bernie
Sanders campaign pitch that his
progressive movement will bring millions
of non voters into the November election
driving record turnout especially among
disaffected working-class Americans and
young people and yet despite a virtual
tie in Iowa a narrow victory in New
Hampshire and a big triumph in Nevada
the first three nominating contests
reveal a fundamental challenge for
Sanders his political revolution he may
be winning but not because of his
long-standing pledge to expand the
Democratic base the results so far show
that Mr Sanders has prevailed by
broadening his appeal among traditional
Democratic voters not by fundamentally
transforming the electorate in other
words the same people are showing up to
vote more of them are just voting for
Sanders and part of that is this
bandwagon effect that happens in the
primaries media attention
builds on media attention and this is
why whenever you have a candidate who
sets up a firewall see Rudy Giuliani in
2008 in Florida whenever you have a
candidate if he sets up a firewall and
that firewall is in state number four
it's too late by that point because what
you have is a wall and then on the other
end you have a snowball that starts off
rolling down the mountain and as it
starts rolling down the mountain and
start secreting more and more snow so
it's getting larger and larger that
snowball is media attention so if you
start off in Iowa and starts rolling
down the hill you're picking up media
attention New Hampshire more media
attention Nevada Nevada more media
attention South Carolina more media
attention by the time you get to this
wall right here boom it just runs right
over the wall and this is what you've
seen in these primaries so people who
have ignored the early primaries have
done so at their own peril I'm talking
to you Mike Bloomberg and I'm talking to
you Joe Biden and so this is why Bernie
has been able to roll over the other
Democrats not because Bernie is bringing
in new audiences but because the
additional media attention makes Bernie
seem inevitable the inevitability
conversation makes it so that people
want to be on the side of a winner it's
just a normal human tendency if you
believe somebody is about to win you
you're more likely to jump on their
bandwagon so you've seen this in the
Democratic polling in the democratic
polling the perception that Bernie
Sanders could win a general election has
risen dramatically over the past month
over the past month a month ago a bare
majority of Democrats thought that
Sanders was the strongest candidate to
face up in a general election as he
started winning primaries that's now
jumping into the 70s and the reason for
that is because people have this bizarre
notion and really isn't I don't think a
thought through process I don't think
that it's really a considered opinion
they just have this instinct that if
somebody is able to win one race they're
able to win another race even if the two
skills are not transferrable in Iowa
says Nate Cohen turnout for the caucuses
was lower than expected up three percent
compared with 2016 the increase was
concentrated in more well-educated areas
where Sanders struggled according to a
New York Times analysis so in other
words Sanders actually didn't do that
great in Iowa there's no sign of a
Sanders voters surge in New Hampshire
either nor on Saturday in Nevada where
the final results indicated the turnout
would finish above 2016 but well short
of 2008 levels despite a decade of
population growth and a new early voting
option that attracted 75,000 voters the
low numbers are all the more striking
says the New York Times given the huge
turnout in the 2018 midterm elections
which was the highest in a century
there's also no evidence across the
early states of much greater
participation by young people
a typically low turnout group that makes
up a core part of Sanders his base and
that he has long said he can motivate to
get out to the polls and Sanders has
struggled to overcome his long-standing
weakness in affluent well-educated
suburbs where democrats excelled in
midterm elections and where many
traditionally Republican voters are
skeptical about from his performance
meaning they could be up for grabs in
November so this means that because the
field is fragmented he could still pull
off the nomination but everybody is just
lying when they suggest that he's going
to be bringing in swaths of new voters
into the Democratic Party it's not a
thing that he is actually doing so
that's a serious problem for him another
serious problem for Bernie Sanders is
this his campaign is filled with jerks
and this is something that his his
people on the Democratic side of the
aisle other candidates have been
pointing out is that Bernie Sanders's
campaign is filled with people who are
just jackasses and this is a hundred
percent true right the Bernie bros are
in fact the nastiest people on the
Internet
they're really really awful they're
awful to other Democrats and that sort
of treatment is not gonna play well in a
general election it isn't because the
Democratic appeal typically is were nice
that's always the Democratic appeal
we're nicer than the Republicans the
Republicans are mean they're nasty
they're cruel and well Bernie bros are
going out there and and attacking people
in the most vicious ways that really
cuts against the Democratic branding
effort one story that has come out in
the last 24 hours by Scott Bixby over at
The Daily Beast uncovered a Bernie
staffer who was mocking Elizabeth
Warren's looks and Pete Buddha judges
sexuality on a private twitter account
according to The Daily Beast during the
most recent presidential primary debate
in Vegas
senator Sanders suggested that critiques
of some of his most antagonistic online
supporters are largely unfounded and
unfair and he proposed that some of the
worst offenders might actually be
Russian trolls on a mission to sow
disunity in the field but the private
Twitter accounts of a newly promoted
campaign staffer indicates that despite
his condemnation of online harassment at
least some of the Vermont senators most
toxic support is coming from inside the
house using the account perma ban banned
Mora a regional field director for the
Sanders campaign based in Michigan has
attacked other Democrats in the field as
well as their family members surrogates
journalists and politically active
celebrities in deeply personal terms
mocking their physical appearance gender
sexuality among other things he tweeted
that senator Amy Klobuchar looks like
her name quote pained chunky and
confused former South Bend mayor Pete
Buddha judge quote is what happens when
therapist watches the conversion and his
husband chasin more predicts will quote
be busted for running a meth racket in
ten years I mean really nice people
really nice people in the Bernie
campaign this doesn't mean everybody
who's voting for Bernie is a nasty
person it does mean that everybody who
seems to be nasty in this race is a
Bernie Sanders supporter that's a real
problem
for Bernie Sanders as well the biggest
problem for Bernie Sanders of course is
Bernie Sanders that is that remains the
biggest problem for Bernie Sanders that
Bernie does not have wide swaths of
support people are whistling past the
graveyard when they suggest he's gonna
bring in new audiences because it turns
out you know what is not supremely
popular being an old bat bleep commie it
turns out that that is really not super
popular in the United States I mean it
is it is almost an incredible thing it's
almost like a it's almost a Philip Roth
novel the fact that Bernie Sanders a
career loser I mean truly a career loser
has made it this far in American
politics it is an object lesson to
people everywhere that anyone can become
presidents of the United States truly
anyone including a man who did not walk
down and chop until he was 39 years old
and was not supporting his own kid
financially even though he's a college
graduate because he was too busy making
single film reels about Eugene Debs as a
socialist I mean that that was seriously
Bernie Sanders his life his life is that
he was running as a Liberty Union
candidate in Vermont and losing every
election in the 1970s and then he
decided you know what I guess I can't be
that much Mikami instead I'm just gonna
run as an independent by the time he
held down his first job he was three
years older than I am now he's three
years older than I am now and people
described him back in those years they
talked about it the fact that he was
living in this run-down apartment that
was incredibly dirty the fact that they
weren't sure if he was paying for his
power like all of this was has been
fairly well reported but it's not just
that listen everybody experiences tough
times in their life the point is that
Bernie Sanders chose to do all of those
things the man was a college graduate he
obviously is not unintelligent he chose
to live this loser lifestyle because he
felt that it was in line with his
socialist principles and then he
immediately upon gaining entrance to
office began hobnobbing with the world's
worst human beings and he continues to
do this because Bernie has never changed
here's the point most people have a
redemption story where were they started
off when they were 15 is not where they
end up when they are 77 78 years old
like burning burning is exactly the same
human being he was at 39 and at 78
and he brags about this so that means
that all that stuff is fair game because
it no point to Bernie actually redeem
himself he just happened to be a guy who
found a government teat to suck off of
for the last sixty years of his life and
we're gonna get more into Bernie Sanders
and his warmth toward communism
momentarily because it really is an
amazing thing I mean it's in America
anything is possible we'll get to this
in just one second first let's talk
about how important it is for you to run
an efficient business if you actually
want to run a business you know not be a
career lifelong loser you run a business
and you open that business gonna make
sure that your data is really up-to-date
and that you're in control of all that
data that you can examine every aspect
of your business every portion of your
business because data is time data is
money well this is why you need NetSuite
an integrated solution to your business
needs successful companies know that in
order to grow faster you have to have
the right tools whether you're doing a
million 10 million hundreds of millions
in revenue NetSuite by Oracle gives you
the tools you need to accelerate your
growth with NetSuite you got a full
picture of your business finance
inventory HR customers and more it's
everything you need to grow all in one
place directly from your phone or
computer
NetSuite will give you the visibility
and control you need to make the right
decisions and grow with confidence which
is why NetSuite customers grow faster
than the S&P 500 NetSuite is the world's
number one cloud business system trusted
by more than 19,000 companies it's the
last system you will ever need NetSuite
because business grows here again
knowing your business there's no
substitute for it if you want to run a
successful efficient business schedule
your free product tour right now and
receive your free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits at
NetSuite comm / Bend that is NetSuite
comm slash man
NetSuite comm slash man n etsu ite comm
slash men go check it out right now ok
so last night Bernie Sanders was on CNN
and he decided that would be a wonderful
idea to double down on his praise for
Fidel Castro and then the biggest
problem for Bernie Sanders in this race
is that Bernie Sanders is Bernie Sanders
and the public has been hidden from the
fact that Bernie Sanders is Bernie
Sanders because the media refused to
cover him for years and when I say they
refused to cover my don't mean they
didn't do reporting there was some good
reporting on him in 2015 2016 but at no
point was he ever asked a tough question
about his overt lifelong support of
every communist regime he could possibly
find and nothing has changed about
Bernie
nothing okay Bernie is exactly this he's
like the high school principal in Back
to the Future the dude never had hair he
is exactly
the same person okay so here is Bernie
Sanders last night on 60 minutes he had
said that sure showed the cuspid I don't
like human rights violations but they
did raise the literacy rates here is
Bernie
defending Cuba and then going on to
defend China truth is truth all right
now if you wanna disagree with me if
somebody wants to say that and by the
way all of those Congress people that
you mentioned just so happen to be
supporting other candidates just
accidentally no doubt coincidentally but
you know the truth is the truth and
that's what happened in the first years
of the Castro regime so there he is
defending the first years of the Castro
regime you know some other truths that
happened during the first years of the
Castro regime the mass execution of
dissidents the imprisonment of
dissidents somewhere between 35,000
175,000 people were either killed or
imprisoned by the Castro regime people
floating off kora off off Cuba in cars
to the coast of Florida okay that is the
regime that Bernie Sanders is defending
there and this is not a shock it really
is not I mean the fact is that this has
been Bernie Sanders his lifelong
principled Bernie Sanders his lifelong
principle from the time that he was
young total time that he is old is that
America is bad and that communist
regimes are inherently good and that
their repression is sort of a nasty side
effect of the fact that they have to
overcome a vicious capitalist system
that they are overthrowing I mean Bernie
has overtly praised the communist
revolution in Cuba
he'll vertically praised it he said that
he back in his the 98 back in his 30s in
the 1980s right when he was my age again
I keep pointing this out cuz when we say
in his youth it makes it sound like when
he was 17 when we all make mistakes no
no he was in his late thirties when he
was talking about this stuff he said
that he had great warmth toward the
communist revolution in Cuba because it
was obviously poor people rising up
against rich people I mean that this
this is who Bernie Sanders has been his
entire life well CNN is finally
reporting on that so John Avlon
did a did a report yesterday about
Bernie's history of praising dictators
and he basically only scratched the
surface this is a clip 11 add to this
Sanders now infamous honeymoon in Moscow
at the end of the Cold War his praise
for the Soviet Union's public
transportation and youth programs well
somehow never finding time to meet with
Nobel Prize winning Russian dissident
Alexander Solzhenitsyn who lived in
Vermont at the time it may speak to
Sanders general sympathies at the time
now I'm not even getting into Sanders
1970s advocacy for nationalizing most
major industries or is
since renounced call to abolish the CIA
or his assertion to a Vermont high
school students in 1972 that some us
action in Vietnam was quote almost as
bad as what Hitler did I'm simply
pointing out that Sanders vision of
democratic socialism has extended far
beyond the danish style welfare state as
he likes to claim now this of course is
100% true John Avlon may find himself in
a Bernie Sanders re-education camp for
having run that particular segments
amusing to watch the media finally pick
up on the fact that this is who Bernie
Sanders is and this is who he is I mean
there's video of Bernie in the Soviet
Union singing shirtless in 1988 okay
that is video that exists him singing
you're this land is your land this land
is my land the old commie song in the
Soviet Union on a trip for his honeymoon
it was a business trip slash honeymoon
with his wife Jane in 1988 in the Soviet
Union right before the Soviet Union fell
here is Bernie there's the old man sure
it was Bernie
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
that's Bernie in Moscow Bernie in Moscow
1988 in the middle of the Soviet Union
unless you believe that this was just
Bernie doing like a goodwill trip
hey let's go through some of the things
that Bernie has said about communist
dictatorships I mean last night by the
way again he has never wavered on this
sort of stuff last night Bernie said
quote we're very opposed to the
authoritarian nature of Cuba but you
know it's unfair to simply say
everything is bad when Fidel Castro came
into office you know what he did get the
massive literacy program it's not a bad
thing even though Fidel Castro did it
yeah when Mussolini quote-unquote came
into office the trains ran on time and
when Hitler came into office he built
the Autobahn like you know what's really
not difficult finding things that
dictators have done that are not
horrible like Hitler had a dog also but
that really isn't the headline here the
headline of the Hitler regime was not
had a dog built the Autobahn and the
headline of the Cuban regime is not
raised literacy rates from 80% to 100%
you know where we've actually been able
to raise literacy rates really well
without you know sliding into monstrous
dictatorship most of the West we've
actually able to do that fairly well as
it turns out it turns out these two
things have nothing to do with each
other
so praising the Cubans for their
literacy programs is really ridiculous
but of course Sanders hasn't merely
praised Castro's literacy programs hit
back in the 1980s Sanders explained that
he was quote the direct quote physically
nauseated by john f kennedy's quote who
played for the cuban revolution and he
said that when he was watching the nixon
kennedy debates cuz he's old enough to
have been 91 those happened bernie
sanders said that he was physically
nauseated by john f kennedy's opposition
to the cuban revolution of 1959 and then
in 1989 sanders visited cuba and he came
back and he said i could not see a
hungry child I could not see only
homeless people ya know bleep you didn't
see hungry child or any homeless people
because you know what communist regimes
do when you show up they hide all of the
hungry children and the homeless people
that's what they do also everyone is
poor and is driving a 1955 Chevy if they
have a car at all and it's 1989 that's a
country frozen in time I mean I friends
who have been there it's a country that
is frozen in time and also I mean again
this is why it's so dishonest for the
media to suggest that Bernie Sanders is
just expressing love for Castro's
literacy programs he said in 1989 quote
the Cuban people had quote an almost
religious affection for Fidel Castro an
almost religious affection for Fidel
Castro
you know why that might be it's cause
some if you don't you go to jail and you
stay there forever and die there that
tends to breed a sort of religious
affection Bernie Sanders is exactly the
sort of fellow who would look at North
Korean be like look at how all the
people get their love King John they
love him it's amazing where all the
people who hate them I don't see them on
the streets they seem fairly happy right
he shoots all of them who don't right
but but again it's not just it is not
just Cuba he has yet to find a communist
regime that he does not support on a
moral level as opposed to the United
States by the way like burning believes
the United States is the root of all
evil
last night Bernie said in some ways we
are not a great country right he'll talk
about how in some ways Cuba is a great
country I'll talk about in some ways the
Soviets are great in some ways the
United States is not great Bernie has in
the past compared American American
soldiers service in Vietnam to the Nazis
I mean this is who Bernie Sanders is he
is Howard Zinn unvarnished Bernie
Sanders is no I'm Chomsky and you guys
are treating him like some mainstream
Democratic candidate it's unreal that
only now a week away from burning
wrapping up the nomination is anybody
picking up on this stuff here is Bernie
on 60 minutes the other night talking
about how America isn't a great country
is America great in many ways we are in
some ways some very significant ways
we're not we're not great when half of
our people today are living paycheck to
paycheck
when 500,000 people tonight are gonna be
sleeping out on the streets well so what
we're not quite in any of that the only
way we would be great is if we solved
all those problems you know who doesn't
have any homeless people Cuba I mean
notice the metric that he is using for
greatness the metric he is using for
greatness is quote unquote economic
equality he's not using as a metric for
greatness freedom he's not using as a
metric for greatness prosperity he's not
using as a metric for greatness the the
ability of the United States of free
people around the world he's not using
any of that as a metric for greatness
but he uses as a metric for greatness
he's a communist marxist metric of
greatness which is equality are we great
one-half of all people a pool enough of
all people are rich first of all it
doesn't even point out that the people
who are poor in the United States by
global standards are not poor but Bernie
this is Bernie Sanders all over me back
to his backing of
four teams in just a moment because the
list goes on and on and on and on it's
this is the the man is a Marxist
he is a Leninist okay the fact that
Bernie Sanders has been able to
masquerade as like an FDR style Democrat
when he is in fact a devotee of Leninism
is insane and the fact of the media are
only picking up on it now and the other
candidates are picking up on it now is
pretty amazing as well and get some more
of this in just one second first gang I
got to tell you a Daily wire membership
is the only way you should be viewing
our content you're missing all our best
features if you are not right now use
promo code at Shapiro you get 10% off
any member plan you choose what makes
membership so great well our members get
articles had free access to all of our
live broadcast and show library the full
three hours of the men Shapiro show
select bonus content access to the
mailbag and more plus our new all-access
chair gets you into an exclusive live
online Q&A discussions with me Andrew
Clavin Matt Walsh Michael moles plus
Daily wire writers and special guests
and don't forget you also get the
greatest of all beverage vessels of
course the left is tears tumbler yes you
get all of that plus 10% off when you
use promo code to Shapiro's stop
depriving yourself come join the fun by
the way next Tuesday March 3rd join me
God King Jeremy boring Andrew Clavin
Michael moles on daily wire backstage we
will watch the results from Super
Tuesday roll in and we'll see if
socialist Bernie Sanders wraps this
sucker up early to make sure that you
tune in for that you're listening to the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so back to Bernie's lifelong
supportive communist regimes again
there's not a single communist regime
that Bernie has not supported at some
level so Bernie said about China last
night he said China is not thought of
terian country but can anyone deny I
mean the facts are clear that they have
taken more people out of extreme poverty
than any country in history okay now
first of all I'm just a very basic root
level this is untrue
the reason it's untrue is because that
is like suggesting its rule I let me
explain why and then I will try to find
an analogy for it
China has brought people out of poverty
by embracing free-market principles that
runs a rectly counter to its communism
so China embraced the idea of free
markets free trade right trade with
other countries they embrace the idea of
a profit margin they embrace the idea of
a certain amount of private property
ownership that would allow growth and
innovation what they've been involved in
is what you would really call
corporatism as opposed to a communist
nationalized ownership of all means of
production this is something that China
did during the 1990s when it was rising
out of poverty that had nothing to do
with Chinese communism so Bernie
suggesting that China has raised people
out of poverty when it was really the
United States in Europe and the free
market system that raises people out of
poverty it's it's sort of like when when
Bernie suggests that the United States
is responsible for income inequality
without recognizing we're responsible
for prosperity like the what is
responsible for the great healthcare
system of the West is capitalism it is
not in fact socialism right it is the
innovation it turns out that everybody
had equal healthcare back in 1732 as
well it's just a really blue it was
quite terrible because nobody had
anything that was worthwhile
scientifically it is one of the things
that Bernie likes to neglect about they
danish the danish medical system
everybody is relying on america to
provide all the medical patents over
half of medical patents happen here in
the united states because we do have a
free market system but this is how
bernie thinks I took a looks at China
and then he's like what can I find a
benefit in China after all that value
equal communist and I like communism
then there's the Communists at
Nicaraguan regime of Daniel Ortega which
murdered thousands of people Sanders
celebrated the sandanista revolution
back in the 1980s even attended a rally
at which protesters chanted Yankees will
die unclear whether he was aware of that
at time he visited Nicaragua oh he was
president while he was at while he was
mayor of Burlington and then he returned
to
Ortega's human rights abuses he actually
went when he when somebody wrote a
letter to him saying you know you seem
to be taking the Ortega abuses rather
non seriously he responded by saying
well you don't understand the
complexities of the situation here in
the United States Abraham Lincoln
suspended habeas corpus
okay comparing Daniel Ortega the
communist oppressor to Abraham Lincoln
the great liberator it's pretty
disgusting it's no wonder that this week
Daniel Ortega when acts by the execrable
max Blumenthal basically endorsed Bernie
Sanders for president that's a thing
that actually happened this week as well
how about the Venezuelan regime last
year Bernie Sanders refused to call
socialist dictator Nicolas Maduro a
dictator he was asked directly about it
on CNN and he said that he sort of
demurred and then when asked if kwan
white oh who is the opposition leader is
the legitimate leader of Venezuela he
said no he said has yet to to actually
find a communist regime for which he
does not have some warmer gears by the
way the Sanders Senate website heard an
editorial from a paper called Valley
news that favorably compared the regime
of Hugo Chavez in poverty reduction with
the poverty record of the United States
and then of course there is Sanders his
long record of propagandizing on behalf
of the Soviet Union it's not just that
Sanders visited the Soviet Union and
went shirtless to sing this land is your
land in Moscow in 1988 he then returned
and declared that Moscow had quote the
most effective mass transit system that
I've ever seen he then celebrated
because again this is exactly what
communists do what communists do is they
say well sure we may have you know
killed all the kulaks but at least you
know that the literacy rates are high I
mean that you can't deny that you can't
deny the literacy is great you can't
deny that the busing in Moscow was
unbelievable sure of a blue Bianca
they're still shooting people in the
basement but the busing is tremendous
have you seen that Subway's unbelievable
and so Bernie Sanders celebrated that
the serene this is such a telling quote
he celebrated that the Soviets were
quote moving forward into some of the
early visions of the revolution what the
revolution was about in 1917 so Bernie
Sanders is just a fan of the Communist
revolution of 1917 I mean he openly said
it in 1989
this is not something who's hiding the
ball right he said in 1989 that the
Soviets were finally moving into the
vision of 1917 which ended with 80 years
or 70 years of from
it's evil right the Russian Revolution
was one of the great tragedies of human
history but Bernie was a big backer he
is not a denmark-norway style social
democrat that is not what he is and
anybody who pretends he is is lying to
you
and so it's kind of fun to watch as the
media discover all of this it's kind of
fun to watch all of this for example so
Jake Tapper yesterday started reporting
on the fact that Bernie Sanders back in
the 1970s was writing weird weird
bizarre fiction pieces in which he
talked about women wanting to be raped
I'd like to see Elizabeth Warren
bringing some for Sanders right she has
plenty of words for Michael Bloomberg
about the stuff he has said to women but
Bernie Sanders writing about how women
enjoy being raped and have fantasies
about it back in the 1970s seriously
this is something Bernie Sanders ROK's
the guy's nut he's an actual nutcase
okay Bernie Sanders is a is a loser
kicked out of a commune when he was in
his when he was in his 30s in Burlington
didn't hold a job and wrote bad fiction
about how women like to be raped and
this guy is who the Democrats are
picking here's Jake Tapper discovering
this there was this essay he wrote when
he was 30 years old in 1971 it's an old
essay but he writes a man goes home and
masturbates his typical fantasy a woman
on her knees a woman tied up a woman
abused a woman enjoys intercourse with
her man as she fantasizes about being
raped by three men simultaneously it
goes on to talk about gender roles it is
very strange and obviously there is a
lot to object-- too in this yeah yeah so
what could someone asked him about that
on stage but anybody anybody that's been
around I quoted this in 2016 when he was
running guys this is not new it's been
around since the 1970s okay that that
weirdo is who you guys are gonna
nominate you are literally about to
nominate the old commie
who hangs out at the library and
creepily stares at the computers because
he doesn't have a job but he has a
guitar and he loves this land is your
land that's you guys are about to
nominate it's unbeliev and CNN finally
noticed yesterday also yeah it's amazing
how CNN which is a mainstream democratic
outlet how yesterday they suddenly
realized hey wait a second Bernie hangs
out with a lot of anti-semites and that
kind of weird like Bernie keeps a keeps
hanging out with like Linda Sarsour and
L Hannah Omar Rasheed Italy yes
I'm simple you noticed congratulations
welcome to the party pal
here's CNN recognizing that Bernie
Sanders may be a little bit on the
anti-semitic side like it doesn't matter
that the man was born Jewish Karl Marx
is born Jewish to that matter
that didn't matter dude hangs out the
anti-semites non-stop and CNN finally
say Oh what like it's stranger CNN
catching on his face criticism from
supporters of Israel on both sides of
the aisle for embracing campaign
surrogates with more extreme anti-israel
views than the candidate they're backing
congresswoman Ilhan Omar and Rasheeda
Talib the first Palestinian American
woman to serve in Congress had both
thrown their support behind Sanders
Sanders has also faced backlash for
surrogates such as Palestinian American
activist Linda Sarsour and honors are a
Palestinian American law professor and
comedian okay yeah and then they should
actually quote those people a majority
of whom have talked about the
destruction of the State of Israel
openly so fun to watch the media finally
fact-checking Bernie in real time
but even Bernie's mainstream campaign
even he's a medicare-for-all campaign is
built on lies so yesterday Pramila
jayapala the congresswoman she is a
Bernie supporter I believe she's from
Washington State and she was touting
Bernie and she starts telling lies about
what Americans believe about their own
medical care well one of the things
that's really funny about Medicare for
all is if you poll Americans on Medicare
for all they don't know what it means
they actually just think that they are
giving more money to Medicaid or that
they are giving more money to Medicare
as like a public option for people who
fall out of their insurance most
Americans don't understand that Bernie
Sanders is plan literally ends the
health insurance industry in the United
States and you lose your health
insurance plan most Americans don't get
that 160 million health plans go away
but here is privilege hiya pal trying to
explain that Americans don't actually
like their health insurance which is
weird because by every poll the vast
majority of Americans with private
health insurance are very fond of their
health insurance as it turns out what do
you say to people who don't want to give
up their their private insurance plans
well I would just say first of all that
nobody likes their private insurance
plan what they like is their doctor and
if you look at all the polling when
people are asked if they want to give up
their private insurance the support goes
down a little if you take the next
question which is if you could keep your
doctor but you were going to have to
give up your private insurance plan this
the pork goes up even higher including
among independents and Republicans okay
but what you're saying is insane because
if you take away their private insurance
they can't have the same doctor now with
the same reimbursement rates not unless
you're gonna cram something down or
nationalize the industry itself I mean
of course this is all wise but Bernie
Sanders his entire campaign is built on
the lie that all he wants his tweaks
around the edges of the system meanwhile
spending his entire career complaining
that the system itself has to be brought
down from within so it's it's fun to
watch people realize this when it's a
little bit too late a little bit too
late they're hit meanwhile president
Trump is facing the Black Swan threat of
coronavirus so coronavirus tanked the
stock market to the tune of about a
thousand points yesterday the Dow Jones
seems to have stabilized a little bit
today even though the bond yields
continued to be incredibly low which
means the demand for bond is high means
that people are very wary of where the
economy is going right now president
Trump's aides according to Politico
faced an increasingly urgent threat
Monday with potentially monumental
implications a global outbreak knocking
down the US economy and walloping
markets in an election year all against
accusations about whether the Trump
administration had mismanaged and
underfunded a critical response with
American lives on the line there really
aren't a lot of cases in the United
States oh it's hard to see exactly how
the United States has dramatically
mismanaged this thing at this point
Stephen Morin informal economic advisor
to the Trump team says the view in the
White House is that this is one of those
classic Black Swan events all we can do
is control the health issues in the
United States the corona virus has
infected more than 78,000 people abroad
although only 53 people in the United
States are confirms have contracted the
virus it's almost entirely overseas it
is largely in countries that do not have
advanced medical systems so Iran is
having serious problems with coronavirus
right now apparently the Deputy Health
Minister over there has coronavirus at
this point and there's threat that is
gonna cross borders in the Middle East
and start infecting a lot of people
there's a lot of talk about China being
adjacent to India that there might be an
outbreak in India which would of course
be a disaster because India is highly
populous of course China is on the hot
seat again as well they should be
because they simply did not handle this
in an appropriate way they banned
information they were they were taking
people who were talking about this thing
and imprisoning them people were being
disappeared now all of this is is scary
I mean coronavirus is scary what it's
mostly scary too in terms of sort of
global health because we don't know the
death rates yet he is really the
because supply lines are being disrupted
Tyler Cowen has a piece of our business
insider today about the disruption of
global supply lines one of the big
problems is what happens if it shuts
down factories in China right the
economy is so intertwined at this point
that if you shut down a factory in China
it has serious impacts on the American
economy and that's what you are seeing
you're seeing global supply lines being
being cut you're starting to see the
economy feel the real effects of all of
this Democrats meanwhile are trying to
militarize this sort of thing they're
trying to weaponize it as is they are
fond of saying and suggest that this is
all Trump's fault in the United States
officials like acting chief of staff
Mick Mulvaney ins Messick policy chief
Joe Grogan have turned their fire on HHS
secretary Alex a czar who's leading the
coronavirus response arguing that a czar
has poorly coordinated strategy failed
to escalate the potential risks to trump
and push for a multi-billion dollar
emergency funding request they initially
viewed as extreme the Trump
administration announced a request for
2.5 billion in emergency coronavirus
cash which would also shift at least 535
million in previously uncommitted funds
funding the response had apparently been
a major sticking point between the White
House and a czar who lobbied to request
additional funds from Congress before he
makes four separate hearings on the hill
this week the package is expected to
face resistance from Democrats who have
warned the Trump administration against
shifting money away from existing
commitments which is a weird look I mean
it's weird for the Democrats to be
obstructing funding for the coronavirus
response at this point the White House
is saying that they are united on this
thing but the the biggest problem here
is of course nobody knows anything about
coronavirus that is the biggest problem
here we don't have a vaccine we don't
know the death rate we don't know the
infection rate China has been hiding all
the stuff it obviously moves fairly
quickly I mean obviously in fact pretty
easily that sort of uncertainty has
significant ramifications for not only
health but for economic certainty and
predictability is the lifeblood of
successful world economies when there's
a lot of uncertainty that leads to
decoupling in global supply lines and
global chains of supply it's gonna hurt
China more than it hurts us but that
doesn't really matter for president
Trump's purposes the bottom line is if
the economy tanks he's got a real
problem on his hands for reelection
in 2020 okay time for a quick thing I
like and then we'll get to some things
that I hate some things that I like
again
big ray bradbury Pam ran another Ray
Bradbury book over the weekend worth
reading a sound of thunder it is sad to
me that that short store
have fallen out of fashion this one is a
little bit less creepy than the one that
I recommended just a couple of weeks ago
this one is more sci-fi stories and Ray
Bradbury sci-fi is really terrific
really in an underrated it's still an
underrated writer because everybody
remembers Fahrenheit 451 but a few
people remember his short stories many
of which are pretty terrific a sound of
thunder I it was it was in the it was in
this in this collection let's say I
believe the sound of thunder is the
story that discusses the butterfly
effect I mean the basic premise is that
somebody goes back in time steps on a
butterfly and it has these dramatic
ramifications across time showing the
ripples across time Bradbury is terrific
the collection is really a lot of fun
you can go check it out a sound of
thunder by ray bradbury okay time for a
quick thing that I hate
okay so thing number one that I that I
really hate so Chris Matthews came out
and apologized to Bernie Sanders
yesterday we live in such a dumb society
I'm sorry did anyone truly think that
Chris Matthews is being anti-semitic
when he talked about historically
speaking in 1940 people didn't realize
that the war had already been lost on
the continent in 1940 before most people
knew it like did anyone really think
that Matthews was comparing Bernie to
Nazis did anyone really think of course
nobody thought that everybody's just
incredibly dishonest and one of the
things that people like to do with
anti-semitism is what I would call the
flattening effect which is every
implication of anti-semitism is treated
as exactly equal even when it's fairly
obvious that there are tremendous
gradations that Bernie Sanders saying
that human might attend a pack because a
pack is racist is significantly worse
for Jews and significantly more
anti-semitic then Chris Matthews talking
about how in 1940 in America a British
General said that the continent had been
overrun right there these are not
comparable they're not comparable
nonetheless Chris Matthews got on the
air last night come to the show come on
their little disappointing with himself
talking about Bernie I'm just gonna
apologize to Burnett I need to do better
don't don't apologize to Bernie dude I
mean seriously it's just ridiculous I
was wrong to refer to an event from the
last days they're actually the first
days of World War two
senator Sanders I'm sorry for comparing
anything from that tragic era in which
so many suffered especially the Jewish
people to an electoral result in which
you were the welders
winter this is gonna be a hard-fought
heated campaign of ideas in the days and
weeks and months ahead I will strive to
do a better job myself of elevating the
political discussion just ridiculous I'm
sorry you remember how many members of
the media have apologized for their
Trump is a Nazi sort of commentary from
2016 any you or have any who have done
that sort of thing of course not of
course not it just shows the double
standard in the media when it comes to
this sort of stuff meanwhile Jim Acosta
being celebrated overseas so he was
overseas with President Trump and
President Trump was speaking in India
and for some reason he calls on Acosta
and that's your first mistake mr.
president never call on Jim Acosta and
ladies find you somebody who loves you
like Jim Acosta loves Jim Acosta I mean
that is that dude who loves him from Jim
Acosta
so Trump calls on Jim Acosta Acosta
starts to yell at Trump from starts to
yell at Acosta and it goes predictably
where you would think it would and then
Jim Acosta tries to sell a few books I
haven't been given help from any country
and if you see what CNN your wonderful
Network said I guess they apologized in
a way for didn't they apologize for the
fact that they said certain things that
weren't fair tell me what was their
apology yesterday what did they say this
president I think our record on
delivering the truth is a lot better
than your some job I don't mind you
saying let me tell you about your record
your record is so bad you ought to be
ashamed of yourself okay and and the
media we're celebrating this Jim Acosta
standing up to the president we
delivered truth a lot more often than
you do mr. president he's a politician
you're a media outlet the fact that you
are you know talking back to the
president I do love that the media they
love themselves so much and they don't
understand why their legitimacy is it
plummets every time they do this that
instead of just sort of allowing Trump
to do what he's gonna do and then
pointing out that Trump is wrong about
something that fighting what the
president makes them look like they are
participants in the drama
rather than observers and covers of the
drama this is the great rap that I've
had on CNN for years I mean I said this
to Don Lemon on CNN I said like if you
want people to take you more seriously
you really do need to make it clear that
you are standing for the American people
and not just for the people at CNN it
looks like in these debates with Trump
that it's Trump versus the media and
that's exactly the battle that Trump
wants and it's the battle the media want
to it's not the media standing there on
behalf of the American people it's Jim
Acosta standing there on behalf of Jim
Acosta or Jim Acosta standing there on
behalf
the CNN higher-ups and and commenting on
the action as a participant well that's
not what the media was ever supposed to
be I mean if the idea is that you're an
objective member of the media and
objectivity is your business then
shouldn't you be objective rather than
being there doing a presidential debate
with with President Trump it just makes
you look bad now listen I understand the
tendency I get it
I do but I just I think that the the
sort of weird celebration of Jim Acosta
for this sort of stuff it doesn't it
doesn't do anything useful for CNN it
doesn't do anything useful for the
political debate okay before I leave I
just have to mention one quick thing
that I like I mentioned it on the radio
show yesterday but I would be missed if
my podcast audience were not informed of
it
Chang Tiger apparently is very very
upset at his own staff for considering
unionizing and that's pretty great
because Chang is a Bernie Sanders guy
and chanc is one of these people who
believes that American industry has been
under unionized and so apparently there
was a meeting on February 12 because his
staff was thinking of unionizing and
which chanc went wild and started
throwing papers on the ground check for
people who don't know the Young Turks is
a wild left network over on YouTube and
so Chang said if you unionize are gonna
hurt our profit margins you're gonna
destroy the business and I have one
response which is um let me just let me
get it together in my head for a second
[Laughter]
yes yes because the fact that shank is
now realizing hey wait a second
unionization has cost for my business
wait a second my business could suffer
if my employees treat me as an
adversarial party as opposed to the
person signing their paychecks wait wait
a second wait hold up is my philosophy
oh my philosophy isn't wrong my
philosophy is right it's just
everybody's mean to me it is fun I root
for reality and the fact that reality
came along and clocked shank directly
across the grill in figurative firms is
fairly delicious so I am enjoying that
and I'm not sure I'll ever stop enjoying
that actually it's pretty wonderful
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
Plus tonight is the last chance for the
Democrats to stop Bernie Sanders we'll
see if they level their fire at him
we'll be back here tomorrow to recap all
of it I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
Whitehouse key technical producer Austin
Stephens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by Mike core Amina hair and
makeup is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20/20 corona virus
is spreading and economies all over the
world are grinding to a halt we will
examine whether we're all gonna die
before we go broke then new polling
shows a big boost to Bernie's chances of
winning the Democratic nomination
freshman representative Ilhan Omar admit
she's unamerican and Harvey Weinstein is
headed for the clink check it out on the
Michael no show
[Music]